again we have these cogs these cogs
techniques where he's going one way
right and I'm going the other way inside
of this one so we don't we don't run
into each other but I don't stay on the
line here there's any number even even
the aggressive ones over here it's just
the card on the back my ride back of my
body to the back of his bar so then then
we always put it aligned right we don't
fly on the grid we don't find out XY
okay so he goes to punch I got a cat
stay down here right so he goes to punch
and I got him in a way you see I've
started to turn the fight okay so I'm
going to start the fight rotating so
that he starts Criss crossing about a
cot across my body that I could use to
create angles of deviation so again he
goes boom and I'm already trying to turn
it one more time you see that so he
wants to come on right or he wants my
back so I keep this there just to get
distance and I push the leg in he wants
to come back now right
so I dive underneath and I pass them to
the other side you see how I'm doing
that so he again she wants to come back
we get to what you want to do he wants
to come in and get straight on me right
so when I put this knee there and he
pushes me I can turn myself
so I won I don't take this knee out yet
and try to go into closed guard I'm
gonna use him coming back on me and he
goes and I'm passing the other way do
you see and then he's gonna come back
again and that's what turned me into my
posture so again we're just going
working on this change the fight started
rotated keep him there but you're not
holding them there
you want him to come back the other way
so as he comes back the other way I go
to the other side as he comes back the
other way it turns me is he comes back
the other way it finishes
okay fine again